et, pour finir, ma capacité à parler.
Quand j'étais à l'hôpital,
je voulais désespérément rentrer.
Je disais à ma mère : « A quand la maison ? »
Ce furent les derniers mots que j'ai prononcés.
Finalement, j'échouais à tous les tests de conscience.
On a dit à mes parents que c'était comme si je n'étais pas là.
Un légume, ayant l'intelligence d'un bébé de trois mois.
On leur a dit de me ramener à la maison et de me mettre à l'aise
jusqu'à ce que je meure.
La vie de mes parents et de toute ma famille
fut consacrée à prendre soin de moi du mieux qu'ils pouvaient.
Leurs amis se sont éloignés.
Une année, deux années,
trois années durant.
Il semblait que la personne que j'avais été commençait à disparaître.
Les Lego et circuits électroniques que j'adorais ont été rangés.
J'étais passé de ma chambre à une autre chambre plus pratique.
J'étais devenu un fantôme,
un vague souvenir d'un garçon que les gens ont un jour connu et aimé.
Pendant ce temps, mon esprit commença à reprendre forme.
Graduellement, ma conscience a commencé à revenir.
Mais personne ne se rendait compte que j'étais revenu à la vie.
J'étais conscient de tout,
comme quelqu'un de normal.
Je pouvais tout voir et comprendre,
mais je ne pouvais le dire à personne.
Ma personnalité était enterrée dans un corps apparemment silencieux,
un esprit vibrant caché à la vue de tous dans une chrysalide.
La dure réalité m'a vraiment frappé :
j'allais passer le reste de ma vie enfermé en moi-même,
complètement seul.
J'étais piégé, avec mes pensées pour seule compagnie.
Je ne pourrais jamais être sauvé.
Personne ne ferait preuve de tendresse envers moi.
Je ne parlerais jamais à un ami.
Personne ne m'aimerait jamais.
Je n'avais ni rêves, ni espoir, rien à attendre.
Enfin, rien de plaisant.
Je vivais dans la peur
et, pour parler franchement,
j'attendais que la mort vienne finalement me libérer,
m'attendant à mourir seul dans une maison de soins.
Je ne sais pas s'il est vraiment possible d'exprimer en mots,
ce que c'est de ne pas être capable de communiquer.
Votre personnalité semble disparaître dans un épais brouillard
et tous vos désirs et émotions sont restreints, étouffés et contenus en vous.
Pour moi, le pire était la sensation de totale impuissance.
Je ne faisais qu'exister.
C'est très sombre de se trouver dans cet état
parce que, en un sens, vous avez disparu.
D'autres personnes contrôlaient tous les aspects de ma vie.
Elles décidaient de ce que je mangeais et quand.
Si j'étais étendu sur le côté ou attaché dans ma chaise roulante.
Je passais souvent mes journées face à la télévision
à voir des rediffusions de Barney.
Je pense que parce que Barney est si heureux et beau,
et que je ne l'étais pas du tout,
cela empirait les choses.
J'étais totalement impuissant et ne pouvais rien changer dans ma vie
ni même la perception que les gens avaient de moi.
J'étais un observateur silencieux du comportement des gens
quand ils pensaient que personne ne regardait.
Malheureusement, je n'étais pas seulement un observateur.
Sans moyen de communiquer, je suis devenu la victime parfaite :
un objet sans défense, apparemment dénué de sentiments
que les gens utilisaient pour accomplir leurs plus sombres désirs.
Pendant plus de 10 ans, les personnes chargées de prendre soin de moi
ont abusé de moi physiquement, verbalement et sexuellement.
Malgré ce qu'ils pensaient, je le ressentais.
La première fois que c'est arrivé,
je fus choqué et incrédule.
Comment pouvaient-ils me faire cela ?
J'étais confus.
Qu'avais-je fait pour mériter cela ?
Une partie de moi voulait pleurer et une autre voulait se battre.
La douleur, la tristesse et la colère m'ont envahi.
Je me sentais superflu.
Personne n'était là pour me réconforter.
Mais aucun de mes parents ne savait ce qu'il se passait.
Je vivais dans la terreur, sachant que cela arriverait encore et encore.
Je ne savais juste pas quand.
je savais juste que je ne serais plus jamais le même.
Une fois, je me souviens avoir écouté Whitney Houston chanter :
« Peu importe ce qu'ils m'enlèvent, ils ne peuvent pas prendre ma dignité. »
Et j'ai pensé : « Tu veux parier ? »
Peut-être que mes parents auraient pu le découvrir et auraient pu aider.
Mais les années de soins constants,
avoir à se réveiller toutes les 2 heures pour me tourner,
essentiellement combinées au deuil de la perte de leur fils,
avaient eu des conséquences néfastes sur ma mère et mon père.
Suite à une autre discussion animée entre mes parents,
dans un instant de détresse et de désespoir,
ma mère s'est tournée vers moi et m'a dit que je devrais mourir.
J'étais choqué, mais en pensant à ce qu'elle avait dit,
j'étais empli de compassion et d'amour pour ma mère,
cependant je ne pouvais rien faire.
Il y a eu de nombreux moments où j'ai abandonné,
plongeant dans de sombres abysses.
Je me souviens particulièrement d'un moment sombre.
Mon père m'a laissé seul dans la voiture
pendant qu'il allait rapidement acheter quelque chose à l'épicerie.
Un étranger est passé,
m'a regardé et a souri.
Je ne saurai peut-être jamais pourquoi, mais cet acte simple,
ce moment éphémère de connexion humaine
a transformé ce que je ressentais,
me redonnant l'envie de continuer.
Mon existence était torturée par la monotonie,
une réalité qui était souvent trop à supporter.
Seul avec mes pensées, je construisais des rêves complexes
sur les fourmis qui couraient sur le sol.
J'ai appris à deviner l'heure en voyant où étaient les ombres.
En apprenant comment les ombres bougeaient au fur à mesure que les heures passaient,
j'ai compris combien de temps il y avait avant qu'on vienne me chercher
pour me ramener à la maison.
Voir mon père passer la porte pour venir me chercher
était le meilleur moment de la journée.
Mon esprit est devenu un outil que je pouvais utiliser,
soit pour me fermer et me retirer de ma réalité,
soit pour l'élargir en un gigantesque espace à remplir de mes rêves.
J'espérais que ma réalité change,
et que quelqu'un voie que j'étais revenu à la vie.
Mais j'avais été emporté comme un château de sable
construit trop près des vagues,
et à ma place était la personne que les gens s'attendaient à ce que je sois.
Pour certains, j'étais Martin, une enveloppe vide, un légume,
méritant des mots durs, le rejet et même des abus.
Pour d'autres, j'étais le garçon souffrant tragiquement de lésions cérébrales
qui avait grandi pour devenir un homme.
Quelqu'un envers qui ils étaient gentils et à qui ils tenaient.
Bon ou mauvais, j'étais une toile vierge
sur laquelle étaient projetées différentes versions de moi-même.
Il a fallu quelqu'un de nouveau pour me voir d'une façon différente.
Une aromathérapiste a commencer à venir à la maison de soins,
environ une fois par semaine.
Que ce soit grâce à son intuition ou son attention pour les détails
que d'autres n'avaient pas vus,
elle est devenue convaincue que je pouvais comprendre ce qu'on disait.
Elle a poussé mes parents à me faire suivre des tests par des experts
en communication alternative et améliorée.
Et en un an,
j'étais capable d'utiliser un logiciel pour communiquer.
C'était exaltant, mais parfois frustrant.
J'avais tant de mots dans ma tête
que j'avais hâte d'être capable de les partager.
Parfois, je me disais des choses simplement parce que je le pouvais.
En moi, j'avais un public attentif,
et je croyais qu'en exprimant mes pensées et vœux,
les autres aussi écouteraient.
Mais en communiquant plus,
je me suis rendu compte, qu'en fait, ce n'était que le début
de la création d'une nouvelle voix pour moi-même.
J'étais projeté dans un monde dans lequel je ne savais pas comment fonctionner.
J'ai arrêté d'aller à la maison de soins
et j'ai réussi à obtenir mon premier travail
à faire des photocopies.
Aussi simple que cela paraisse, c'était génial.
Mon nouveau monde était vraiment excitant
mais souvent un peu écrasant et effrayant.
J'étais comme un homme-enfant
et, aussi libérateur que cela fut,
j'avais des difficultés.
J'ai aussi appris que beaucoup de ceux que je connaissais depuis longtemps
trouvaient impossible d'abandonner l'idée de Martin qu'ils avaient en tête.
Alors que ceux que je rencontrais juste
avaient du mal à voir au-delà de l'image de l'homme silencieux en chaise roulante.
J'ai réalisé que certains m'écoutaient seulement
si ce que je disais était en accord avec ce à quoi ils s'attendaient.
Autrement, ils le négligeaient
et faisaient ce qu'ils pensaient être le mieux.
J'ai découvert que la vraie communication
est plus que simplement transmettre physiquement un message.
C'est faire entendre et respecter le message.
Mais cela avançait.
Lentement, mon corps devenait plus fort.
J'avais un travail que j'adorais dans l'informatique
et j'avais même eu Kojak, le chien dont je rêvais depuis des années.
Cependant, je désirais partager ma vie avec quelqu'un.
Je me souviens regarder par la fenêtre quand mon père me ramenait du travail,
pensant que j'avais tellement d'amour en moi et personne à qui le donner.
Juste alors que je m'étais résigné à être célibataire durant le reste de ma vie,
j'ai rencontré Joan.
Elle n'est pas seulement la meilleure chose qui me soit jamais arrivée.
elle m'a aidé à braver les idées fausses que j'avais de moi.
Joan disait qu'elle était tombée amoureuse de moi à travers mes mots.
Cependant, après tout ce que j'avais traversé,
je ne pouvais pas m'empêcher de croire
que personne ne pouvait vraiment voir au-delà de mon handicap,
et m'accepter pour qui j'étais.
J'ai aussi eu de vraies difficultés à comprendre que j'étais un homme.
La première fois que quelqu'un a parlé de moi en tant qu'homme,
j'ai marqué une pause.
J'avais envie de regarder autour et de demander : « Qui, moi ? »
Cela a changé avec Joan.
Nous avons une connexion géniale,
j'ai appris à quel point il est important
de communiquer ouvertement et honnêtement.
Je me sentais en sécurité.
Cela m'a donné la confiance pour dire ce que je pensais vraiment.
J'ai commencé à me sentir entier à nouveau.
J'ai commencé à refaçonner mon destin.
J'ai donné un peu plus mon opinion au travail.
J'affirmais mon besoin d'indépendance aux gens autour de moi.
Qu'on me donne un moyen de communication a tout changé.
J'ai utilisé le pouvoir des mots et de la volonté
pour mettre en question les préjugés
des gens autour de moi, et de moi-même.
La communication est ce qui nous rend humain,
nous permettant de nous lier profondément
à ceux qui nous entourent --
raconter notre propre histoire,
exprimer des vœux, des besoins et des désirs,
ou entendre ceux des autres en écoutant vraiment.
C'est comme ça que le monde sait qui nous sommes.
Donc qui sommes-nous sans cela ?
La vraie communication augmente la compréhension
et crée un monde plus bienveillant et compatissant.
J'ai été une fois perçu comme étant un objet inanimé,
le fantôme sans esprit d'un garçon dans une chaise roulante.
Aujourd'hui, je suis tellement plus.
Un mari, un fils, un ami,
un frère, un entrepreneur, un diplômé major de sa promotion,
un photographe amateur passionné.
C'est ma capacité à communiquer qui m'a donné tout cela.
On nous dit que les actions ont plus de poids que les mots.
Mais je me demande :
est-ce vrai ?
Nos mots, quelle que soit la façon dont nous les communiquons,
sont tout aussi puissants.
Que nous disions les mots de nos propres voix,
qu'on les tape avec nos yeux,
qu'on les communique non-verbalement avec quelqu'un parlant pour nous,
les mots font partie des outils les plus puissants.
Je suis venu ici, j'ai traversé des moments terriblement sombres,
je m'en suis sorti grâce à des âmes bienveillantes,
et grâce au langage.
Le fait que vous m'écoutiez aujourd'hui m'amène plus loin dans la lumière.
Nous brillons ici ensemble.
S'il y a un obstacle plus difficile dans ma façon de communiquer,
c'est que parfois j'aimerais crier
et d'autres fois simplement chuchoter un mot d'amour ou de gratitude.
Mais ma parole est constante.
Mais si vous voulez,
imaginez ce dernier mot aussi chaleureusement que possible :
Merci.
(Applaudissements)